mide el ángulo en grados aquí tenemos
este ángulo azul y lo queremos medir en
grados y está dibujado encima de este
círculo este círculo en realidad es un
transportador tal vez estés acostumbrado
a ver transportadores que tienen la
forma de un semicírculo algo así
y esos transportadores miden de 0 a 180
grados lo cual está bien pero tener un
círculo es mejor un círculo completo es
mejor porque un ángulo podría medir
hasta 360 grados así que un círculo
completo nos permite medir ángulos de
cualquier tamaño en lugar de sólo poder
medir ángulos hasta de 180 grados ahora
la manera en que mediremos este ángulo
es igual que si lo hiciéramos con un
transportador semicircular lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es asegurarnos de
que uno de los rayos del ángulo coincida
con el cero entonces aquí está uno de
los rayos y coincide con el cero en el
transportador
así que ya fue alineado y ahora tenemos
que medir la abertura de todo el ángulo
hasta el otro rayo hasta aquí entonces
si nuestro ángulo estuviera abierto
hasta aquí sería un ángulo de 10 grados
si estuviera abierto hasta acá sería un
ángulo de 50 grados pero nuestro ángulo
tiene toda esta abertura hasta acá hasta
160 grados así que la medida de nuestro
ángulo es de 160 grados
y lo repetiré cuando medimos con un
transportador circular con cualquier
transportador para este caso tenemos que
alinear uno de los rayos con el cero y
luego medir la abertura hasta llegar al
otro rayo que en este caso tiene una
medida de 160 grados